c'était le 25 mars dernier sur le tarmac
de l'aéroport de mulhouse
nous soignons qui se battent aujourd'hui
pour sauver des vie se sont hier battu
souvent pour sauver l'hôpital
notre médecine l'engagement que je
prends ce soir pour eux et pour la
nation toute entière
c'est qu'à l'issue de cette crise un
plan massif d'investissements et de
revalorisation de l'ensemble des
carrières sera construit pour notre
pitre c'était ensuite le 13 avril au
soir sous la halle helmand à l'elysée il
nous faudra rebâtir une indépendance
sanitaires cela passera par un plan
massif pour notre santé notre recherche
alors l'hôpital at il vraiment besoin de
plus d'argent
oui oui oui oui il faut sans doute plus
d'argent pour l'hôpital et en même temps
ça ne pète qu'une question de moyens
c'est pas une question d'argent
les allemands avec - ou beaucoup mieux
que nous dans vos commentaires
vous êtes divisés il y a ceux qui
répondent oui sans hésiter et il ya ceux
qui répondent non
ou bien oui mais alors y at-il vraiment
besoin que d'argent
c'est la question à l'est la vraie
question a demandé
[Musique]
et donc je vous propose de retrouver le
docteur patrick peloux auteurs
dernièrement de cette tribune sur
firefox ce qu'il faut changer dans notre
système de santé
à l'opposé le docteur laurent alexandre
et céistes entrepreneur à succès est
également chirurgien également d'écouter
de débuter l ère de la sarthe jean carl
grenier vous ne connaissez peut-être pas
mais il a signé récemment
ce livre nous nous sommes tant tromper
cette aux éditions du rocher
il révèle que le naufrage date de bien
avant le crash du coronavirus il
démontre et ils démontent les
responsabilités les mécanismes la
responsabilité des politiques des
responsables administratifs de
l'idéologie aussi et surtout des lobbys
ces deux éditions du rocher
et c'est passionnant et enfin l'analyste
libéral fergane asie harry chercheur à
l'ires f
le cimt ans qui traque des impôts et les
lourdeurs fiscale
tout le monde est d'accord tout le monde
le reconnaît il faut tout de suite
et d'abord revaloriser les soignants en
particulier les infirmiers les
infirmières augmenter la rémunération
des personnels de santé c'est
effectivement souhaitable
et en effet quand on prend les quatre
noms ocde on se rend compte qu'ils font
partie des plus mal payés parmi les pays
développés
leur salaire correspond à au 26e rang de
l'échelle des salaires de 2 lots c d e
les infirmières françaises sont moins
bien payés que les infirmières turque et
croate
on est là au coeur de cette crise et on
a vu le dévouement des soignants des
médecins hospitaliers qui n'ont pas des
rémunérations comparable à ce qu'on
pourrait trouver dans d'autres pays mais
également dans le secteur privé
on a des infirmiers on a des aides
soignants on a des brancardiers des
manipulateurs radio qui ont été en
première ligne dans la crise et qui ont
des rémunérations qui sont aujourd'hui
indigne donc il faut repenser revisiter
la grille de l'ensemble des personnels
hospitaliers
tout le problème en fait est de savoir
comment et là il y a une vraie fracture
entre ceux qui veulent puiser d'abord
dans les caisses de l'état et là ils ont
des arguments de vrais arguments mais je
voudrais juste simplement vous préciser
que si tous les ans on a les yeux rivés
sur les comptes de la sécurité sociale
ou ne les a pas sur les autres
politiques publiques personnes dans les
services de l'état n'étant capacité à
vous dire quelle est la part du déficit
annuel de l'état imputable à l'éducation
nationale imputable à la culture
imputable à la défense imputable à la
sécurité intérieure
ce qui n'empêche pas en 2020 de
réinjecter près de 800 millions d'euros
supplémentaires dans le budget de
l'éducation nationale ce qui n'est pas
arrivé dans le budget de la santé depuis
plus de 25 ans qu'elle en fait depuis
des années on nous vote un budget
déficitaire que nous a imposé les 35
heures sans renforts de personnel donc
ça entraîné un dysfonctionnement
c'est ça la vérité nous on est prêts à
faire c'est un système de santé moderne
et qui fonctionne si ici on ne fait pas
un effort financier et budgétaire
on va casser
d'un autre côté il en faut plus pour
convaincre les libéraux il ya plus de
pognon
donc il va y avoir des arbitrages on ne
pourra pas tout faire
on va pas pouvoir payer le chômage
partiel qui coûtent des milliards et des
milliards multiplier par deux le salaire
des infirmières même si sans doute le
mérite créer plein de nouvelles places
de réanimation dans les hôpitaux
financer et subventionner les
entreprises qui sont en train de mourir
et qui reste que de racheter d'être
rachetée notamment par des entreprises
chinoises qui l ont gardé une bien
meilleure santé financière
on pourra pas tout faire que quelles que
soient vos performances
il y aura toujours le contribuable qui
sera forcé de vous financer donc les
hôpitaux français
le système hospitalier français en fait
est financée et rémunéré indépendamment
de ses performances
là encore où il y à un débat avec des
vrais arguments de chaque côté c'est
quand on pose la question faut-il plus
de médecins en clair faut-il comme le
demande patrick peloux relevé numerus
clausus et créer mille places
supplémentaires dès cette année
parce que le nombre d'étudiants en
médecine français d'accord qui ont voulu
faire des études de médecine qui ont
raté à quelques points à qui on a dit
vous êtes mauvais parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas 13 de moyenne
d'accord les parents qui se sont vus et
devoir faire les études de leurs mômes
en suisse en belgique et pendant ce
temps là on va embaucher des médecins
étrangers qui sont souvent compétents
souvent moins compétents d'accord mais
on les soupes est à ce jour le besoin le
plus criant dans toute la france en
ville comme à la campagne
c'est en médecine générale
l'augmentation du numerus clausus quelle
certitude nous donne tels que dans dix
ans quand on aura fini de former les
nouveaux médecins
on aura plus de jeunes à faire le choix
de la médecine générale plus de jeunes à
faire le choix d'un exercice libéral et
plus de jeunes à faire le choix du
secteur rural absolument aucun autre
question faut-il plus de lits dans les
hôpitaux
et là encore débat ardue
faut augmenter le nombre de lits on le
voit avec les lits de réanimation
médicale
il faut ré ouvrir les lits de
réanimation médicale partout sinon ça
mais ça n'ira pas que la médecine du 21e
siècle a besoin de moins de lits
personnellement j'ai subi une opération
sur le rhin et juste avant le
confinement
je suis rentré le matin et j'ai été
opéré pendant la matinée est à 4 heures
je prenais un café en face de la
clinique
la même opération en 1970 j'aurais passé
30 jours à la clinique
nous sommes rentrés dans une phase où la
médecine la chirurgie ont beaucoup moins
besoin de lits que dans le passé il ya
quand même un consensus il y a même une
urgence il faut dégraisser le mammouth
administratif il n'est plus question que
les impôts servent à financer des postes
administratifs dans les hôpitaux
c'est ce qu'ils écrivent patrick peloux
dans sa tribune il dénonce également le
carcan des normes et là tout le monde
est d'accord on n'a plus un ministère de
la santé on en a désormais 14 puisque
avec les agences de régionale de santé
on a désormais un ministère à paris et
13 dans chacune des provinces
ça n'a pas facilité la non plus ni la
gestion de la crise
c'est l'écho que que l'on a sur
l'ensemble des territoires ni le
désengorgement normatif et
administratifs de nos hôpitaux beaucoup
de fédérations professionnelles se sont
plaints de procédure d'homologation
beaucoup trop lourde pour effectuer des
tests pour fournir les services qui
permettrait à la population française
d'être beaucoup plus résiliente et il
faut arrêter de bureaucratiser moi j'ai
été appelé en tant que médecin à
l'hôpital public par l'augmentation
exponentielle du nombre de comités
théodule et du nombre de structures
bureaucratiques dans les hôpitaux
il va falloir maintenant que les
hôpitaux se concentre davantage sur le
choix et qui est qu'on détruise une
bonne partie des comités théodule qui se
sont accumulées depuis 50 ans si vous
appréciez cette vidéo si vous appréciez
ce débat merci
le dire par un pouce levé sur youtube et
bien sûr merci de partager cette vidéo
aller avant de se quitter je vous livre
ce témoignage je suis allé aux urgences
à vannes il y a deux mois un samedi
après-midi il y avait du personnel mais
il en aurait fallu cinq fois plus
tellement il y avait de gens en attente
sur des brancards dans les couloirs
de même il n'y a pas assez de chambres
dans ce service dont je ne suis pas sûr
que le gouvernement comprenne bien les
besoins qui ne sont pas que financier
malgré tous ces problèmes
on s'est très bien occupé de moi et avec
le sourire
merci à eux l'internaute qui signe ce
témoignage c'est donner un surnom tout
fout l'camp
et bien quand je lis ce témoignage non
tout ne faut pas le camp en tout cas à
mon avis
[Musique]